i ask unanimous consent that the senate
proceed to the immediate consideration
of h.r 8472 which was received from the
house
the clerk will report
h.r 8472 an act to provide that due to
the disruptions caused by covet 19
applications for impact aid funding for
fiscal year 2022
may use certain data submitted in the
fiscal year 2021 application
is there objection to proceeding
well the objection the center will
proceed mr president i ask unanimous
consent that the bill be considered
read a third time and passed and that
the motion to reconsider be considered
made
and laid upon the table is there
objection
without objection thank you mr president
[Music]
so
this uh
okay
[Music]
do
foreign
culture motion we the undersigned
senators in accordance with the
provisions of rule 22 of the standing
rules of the senate
do hereby move to bring to a close
debate on the nomination of eileen
mercedes cannon of florida
to be united states district judge for
the southern district of florida
signed by 17 senators
by unanimous consent the mandatory
quorum call has been waived the question
is
is it the sense of the senate that that
debate on the nomination of
mercedes cannon uh florida to be united
states district judge for the southern
district of florida shall be brought to
a close